Here are some things that I meal prep
to make my week a little easier.
I had some ripe bananas that needed to be used,
so the only right way to use them
is making banana bread.
This is a one bowl,
super simple recipe,
and it comes out perfectly moist every single time.
I usually add some chocolate chips to it,
but I didn't this time
to make it a little bit more versatile.
Then I got started on some whipped robus honey butter.
This is so good on the banana bread,
but even other things.
So I added my robus to the melted butter and some honey
and whipped it over ice until it got super creamy.
Then I put it all in a little glass jar
and put that away in the fridge.
I've been loving carrot salad,
so I decided to make a rainbow carrot salad
because it stores really well
and it can be put on anything.
So I add some oil,
vinegar, lemon,
honey, some spices, cilantro,
and I usually put this on toast with some cream cheese
or even just on its own.
It works in a lot of different ways.
You guys know what time it is?
As soon as you guys see me pull out those purple onions.
We're pickling onions today.
I slice them up really thin
and then dissolve my sugar with some vinegar,
salt, and water.
Then I put all of that in a Mason jar,
add some Pepper corn to it
and put it away to rest.
Today I decided to switch up my blueberry sauce
to raspberry sauce.
So I added my frozen raspberries to a pot
with some coconut sugar and lemon.
Let that reduce
until it got to the thickness I wanted it to get.
This is so good when it's warmed up
on some vanilla ice cream.
Last but not least,
I wanted to just make a batch of chicken noodle soup.
It comes in so handy!
So I diced up all of my vegetables
and then added them to the pot with some ginger,
a lot of garlic
and a sprinkle of turmeric.
And half of this batch
I popped in the freezer to thaw whenever I need.